Did I ever show you the picture of the tree that was growing in my toilet pipe
now tree now dude,
I was having a problem.
My toilet wouldn't flush correctly,
so I had a fellow come over to take care of it and he said,
dude,
he goes,
look at that.
That's an actual picture of the thing that was in my bathroom.
What is it that is a tree that that's roots got into a small crack in the water
pipe and then it grows where the water up the pipe.
So the pipe was clogged with like a tree.
It looked like an animal.
Oh my God.
It's disgusting.
That's so big.
It looks like it has a personality.
Tell him the rest of the trees get in here,
Bro.
There's water and shit.
Wait a minute.
In a pipe.
Yeah.
You live in a stew of water and shit and they keep dropping shit on you every
day and you absorb it.
No Way.
You live there.
Yeah,
Bro.
There's no dirt ditches,
watery and they let you live,
Bro.
I'm telling you dirt sucks.
Fuck dude,
that sounds shit.
Pipe.
He's out there hustling.
He made his way up to ship pipe here about Harry.
Yeah Bro.
He worked at that fucking pipe for years,
man.
You got to admit the dude put his timing.
All right.
There's a lot of weeds out there that are complaining about Harry,
but these fuckers,
they grow real fast and then they just stay the same size.
They're not hustlers.
I Dunno.
Harry seems happy,
but could he be the,
I mean,
I would miss the sun personally.
I'd miss the sunshine.
You say that.
Okay.
But Harry's mostly a route could be out there in the dirt and occasionally peak
up a little good,
pointless,
sad routes that have the story of the two.
The rest of their root system.
Like they there were up above and the rest of the roots like what's going on up
there?
Shut the fuck up.
The deer's gonna eat the little saplings.
Hi,
Miss Harry.
Yeah.
Harry was a hustler.
Harry is the Jay Z of tree roots.
Do.
Did you hear how he got busted wide?
Yeah.
This plumber came in.
He got an ambitious,
they rip them out.
I was telling you got to stay small.
You get too big,
you fucking salad keys every day,
and that's when they come for you.
That's behind the music all over again.
That is terrible.
It is behind the music,
goddammit.
You're right.
How are we got too big?